Neil deGrasse Tyson you probably know
he's become sort of American scientists
you doing cosmos on box right now which
is really really fantastic if you're not
watching
you should be watching it I so he
brought up on his radio show
on star talk radio that basically we
shouldn't be giving
equal time to climate change denier XAS
were given to actual scientists who
believe in climate change
he was talking to CNN's miles o'brien
take a listen accuracy in journalism
that leads to
with that what's this phrase is it fair
and balanced are
had to ask mild was with Bayern balance
movement that we've been hearing about
the check it out
on some stories have one-sided is
represented by CAA ninety-five percent
in the scientific community the world
is it fair in a story about climate
change what am I was he talking about
I'm
to do this classic journalistic
Convention No equal time for both sides
this is a huge mistake I think
virginia's
$295 per cent and then is a5 percent you
get a person from that five percent
right now get 50 percent return is ax
serving the truth
I would civic here not is matter fact
that is
beating obfuscation that is actually
perpetuating
Amir dare I say online all right now I
am completely with you miles o'brien the
here that they give you what cosmos
every animated section cosmos is a
and and I'm not saying that any of these
people write it every animated sections
about out
this guy said something that no one
believed and no one would listen to him
and had they not listen to add a you
know continue not to listen to this one
percent
then we would never have gravity or
whatever the hell
so they're something fundamentally wrong
about the logic here
yes I get that left side are you on
their own
argument against them climbing the night
there's there's a better argument
against letting idiots speak yeah you
know that and then this one
this the logic here does it doesn't play
out because like every
scientific idea that has ever been
adopted on a large scale started with a
small-scale see can't go with the 95 25
aspect of it you know a hundred percent
of people thought the world was flat
until they prove that wrong so that
that's just that a logical thing I think
to graft I think about authority watch
this show they get the cosmos you get
that thing like
some people had picked on all their
lives and when they get to be cool
may just are cool near the draft I could
still is pasted people like he is now
like meeting out his vengeance on Polk
and he gets like he takes like way too
long on the cosmos to talk about
the the 88 climate deniers like rapa
girl
it agree with you there is like a five
percent like rubbing in their nose que
thing I actually I I don't mind it I am
what do you think should
when we talk about climate change or
what CNN at all the networks basically
do what happens they give fifty fifty no
matter what is based in science
ninety-seven percent as I disagree seem
to get a guy should get 50 percent
yet I mean fair and balanced turn on
them and
but are we talking like does that mean
that FAC
just doesn't exist that the news
reporting to mr. height because I feel
like
a I do they provide a 50-50 Fairmount
I'm sure they're not giving fifty per
cent break you
I'm going right by the numbers but I
doubt they're getting fifty percent to
the climate change I don't know I mean I
i mean in general journal helmet if he's
talking about journalism
but me baith on you know in equal time
and
in in perspective viewpoint or accuracy
at all I just
don't feel as though you know faction
even be a this thing in this world that
they gave
and but it and actually fit your bike
they actually just it the fact that they
just came out and said actually said
that climate change is real
that shit a hundred percent go ahead go
take that last
3 percent and yes prove that cut the
Antarctic
is currently melting into ourselves
right now there's a piece of the
Antarctic that's like what do they say
it like 20 times the size of Manhattan
right just fell off and it's melting
there's nothing we can do in miami's
gonna disappear
so how do we honestly have a debate
about is there any detail is there any
purpose of having a debate
I think I agree that be proportion of
time
spent talking like up people who know
what they're talking about people who
don't know what they're talking about I
get that the proportion is
of and they should adjust who is allowed
to speak for how long
but I think we need to go the other way
up what Neil deGrasse Tyson is a
I think we need to let the idiots speak
longer have because that's the most
entertaining thing for me to give that
ninety-five percent of the time
because it entertaining because it's so
stupid and then you left for an idiot
talk for long enough and %uh put their
foot in their mouth and no
expose has to get back to that sort of
the theory that you know Bill Nye
the Science Guy did the debate with the
guy from the creation thing and you
believe that Jesus was riding a dinosaur
basically and a lot of people that are
they were saying well he just let him
hang themselves so in
that year like John Oliver did that
thing where he let
he brought on 97 yes I am here yeah
a debate against the re a non
where weirdo jesus's she should leave a
scientist be
president we're just talking about we
could maybe have a gay president do you
think maybe it's time that we had like a
headband
yeah if a site is that without at the
very nature
yeah yeah no really couldn't you
regulate the site is rising like someone
who's actually based in fact
and not in arrested in
money or immersion yeah and I think that
that would be a great idea
I'm going to take the next couple months
to go get my doctor ai back
but iraq do you want to tell the camera
again like he did yet but I will be
studying
very hard for the next four months don't
worry I'll be back
to be mac DVD or for scientific lesbian
cuz I
up